When you present the facts to your audience,...
...the audience immediately begins to analyze your presentation content.
And when a person is analyzing something,...
...they are generally not excited by that thing.
What this means is that the person becomes bored almost instantly.
So what do you do?
What you should do when you are given a presentation topic...
...and criteria for your presentation...
...is to immediately begin thinking in terms of a story...
...with a beginning, middle and end...
...and some sort of problem or situation to overcome.
Even better is to make that problem or situation...
...something that is dramatic, that has a time restriction,...
...and where the consequences are very severe.
If you can't do that or it's too difficult,...
...then tell a human story of where you were, where you wanted to go...
...and how you got there or are still working at getting there.
This type of presentation style, no matter what the topic or criteria,...
...is definitely possible.
But the major benefit of this presentation style...
...is to draw the audience into your presentation.
Keep their attention and not allow them to analyze your presentation.